THIS IS  "THE FIVE" -- THIS IS
"THE FIVE."
CHAOS, CONFUSION, MASS
CANCELLATIONS.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LIVING THEIR
WORST TRAVEL NIGHTMARES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES CANCELING
NEARLY 2,000 FLIGHTS AND THAT
INSTRUCTION CONTINUES TODAY WITH
MORE THAN 350 BEING CALLED OFF
AND ANOTHER 750 DELAYED.
FRUSTRATION BOILING OVER FOR
PASSENGERS WHO SAY THEY WERE
COMPLETELY BLINDSIDED.
>> WE DIDN'T FIND OUT UNTIL 5:00
THIS MORNING THAT IT WAS
CANCELED.
WE WERE ON THE PHONE FOR SEVEN
HOURS.
IT WAS SO BACKLOGGED.
>> SAID THEY WERE HAVING
PROBLEMS.
THEY DIDN'T SAY WHAT IT WAS AND
"YOU'RE LUCKY YOU GOT A FLIGHT."
BECAUSE THE WEATHER IS FINE AND
ALL COLLECTING AREAS.
CONNECTING AREAS.
THAT HAS TO BE SOMETHING WE
HAVEN'T SEEN.
>> Dana: SOUTHWEST BLAMING IT
ON AIR TRAFFIC CONTROL AND
SEVERE WEATHER.
THE FAA CONTRADICTING IT SAYING
IT'S NOT TO BLAME FOR WHAT
HAPPENED.
THE CANCELLATIONS, DURING A
CONTROVERSY OVER THE AIRLINES
VACCINE POLICY.
SOUTHWEST AND ITS PILOTS UNIONS
DENYING IT HAD ANYTHING TO DO
WITH THE WAVE OF CANCELLATIONS
BUT ONE PILOT DID WARN IT COULD
LEAD TO SHORTAGES.
STICK WITH IT GOING TO BRING THE
AIRLINE INDUSTRY TO ITS KNEES.
THEY CAN'T OPERATE WITH A 10%
LOSS OF THEIR WORKGROUPS.
IT AFFECTS THE CONSUMER.
WE DON'T JUST FLY PEOPLE.
WE FLY ORGANS, BLOOD FOR
HOSPITALS, MEDICAL EQUIPMENT,
FRESH FOOD.
IT'S GOING TO AFFECT THE
ECONOMY.
IT'S GOING TO AFFECT YOUR
LIFESTYLE.
IT'S GOING TO AFFECT THE
MARKETS.
IT'S A BIG DEAL.
>> Dana: GREG, SEEMS LIKE
AIRLINES FORGET IT'S NOT THE
1980s.
IF THEY SAID THAT THERE WAS A
WEATHER ISSUE, YOU ARE LIKE,
OKAY.
NO WAY TO TELL.
NOT EVERYBODY HAS IT ON THEIR
PHONE.
>> Greg: WILL YOU ARE SEEING
IS GOVERNMENT ISN'T CONTROLLING
THIS.
ITS PILOTS.
IF THIS IS TRUE.
IF IT'S ACTUALLY ABOUT THE
MANDATES, THEN YOU'RE SEEING A
GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO DECIDE THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT ENOUGH THAT THEY
CAN ACTUALLY CONTROL A RESOURCE
THAT CAN PUT A STOP TO ANYTHING
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO.
THE PERSONAL IS ALWAYS POLITICAL
FOR THE LEFT.
DECADES AGO IT WAS ESSENTIAL
WITH JIM CROW, MAKES A PERSONAL
BUT NOW EVERYTHING PERSONAL IS
POLITICAL EXCEPT I AM WILLING TO
BET THAT 99% OF THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE INVOLVED IN THIS STANCE,
IT'S NOT US VERSUS THEM.
IT'S NOT A POLITICAL THING.
I THINK IT'S A PERSONAL THING.
IT'S ABOUT THEIR FAMILIES AND
THE DECISIONS THEY WANT TO MAKE
ABOUT THEIR BODIES BUT WHEN THE
LEFT INTRODUCED POLITICS, IT
BECOMES A PRISON OF TWO IDEAS.
OKAY, YOU'RE EITHER FORWARD OR
YOU'RE AGAINST IT.
DEMOCRAT, REPUBLICAN.
I THINK THAT LEAVES OUT, IT
CROWDS OUT THE REASONS AND
STORIES AND REALITIES THAT
PEOPLE ARE BASING THEIR
DECISIONS ON.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THESE PILOTS
ARE DOING.
I ALSO THINK WE ARE AT A STAGE
WHERE WE KEEP REDEFINING NORMAL
EVERYDAY STUFF.
LOOK AT AUSTRALIA RIGHT NOW.
THE ACCELERATED GOVERNMENT
INTERVENTION IN THE NAME OF
ACCEPTABLE RISK.
THEY KEEP MAKING RISK AND RISK
LESS ACCEPTABLE.
UNTIL THE GOVERNMENT SHOWS UP AT
YOUR HOUSE BECAUSE YOU WENT TO A
ANTI-VACCINE MANDATE PROTEST.
THERE IS NOT GOING TO BE A
MANDATE.
MASKS DON'T HAVE TO BE WORN
OUTSIDE BUT EVERY DAY IT
SLIGHTLY CHANGES.
SOMETHING BECOMES MORE
ACCEPTABLE.
POPULATION FALLS MORE AND MORE
IN LINE IT MAKES YOU WONDER,
WHAT WILL IT BE LIKE IN 22 OR
23?
HOW MUCH WILL HE ACCEPT?
>> Dana: WHAT COULD WE BE LIKE
IN TWO MONTHS?
THE LEFT'S WAR ON CHRISTMAS
COULD CONTINUE WITH DELAYS AND
SHORTAGES OF PILOTS RIGHT AROUND
THE HOLIDAYS.
>> Jesse: MAYOR PETE IS GOING
TO HAVE HIS HANDS FULL.
HE'S IN CHARGE.
WHERE IS MAYOR PETE?
ALL THIS LABOR ACTION BEFORE THE
HOLIDAYS, CHRISTMAS.
>> Greg: IT IS JESSE JR.'S
FIRST CHRISTMAS, HE MUST HAVE
STRONG FEELINGS.
>> Jesse: HE DOES HAVE STRONG
FEELINGS.
HE SAID DAD, JOE BIDEN WANTS
THIS.
HE WAS BRAGGING ABOUT COMPANIES
LAYING OFF THE UNVAXXED SO THIS
IS EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
SLAP A MANDATE LIKE THIS.
DANA, IF YOU READ THE LATEST IN
"THE FEDERALIST" AND I'M SURE
YOU HAVE.
THE VACCINE MANDATE IS A MIRAGE.
THE RULE HAS NEVER BEEN WRITTEN.
IT MIGHT NOT BE WRITTEN.
ONCE IT'S WRITTEN, HAS TO GO
THROUGH LAWYERS AND THEN ONCE
IT'S ESTABLISHED, IT IS SIX
MONTHS UNTIL COMPANIES HAVE TO
DO ANYTHING SO THE COMPANIES
FELL IN LINE OVER A PRESS
RELEASE, OVER A THREAT.
NOW YOU'RE SEEING THE RESULTS OF
THAT THREAT.
I WAS IN CALIFORNIA OVER THE
WEEKEND GIVING A SPEECH.
I RAN INTO, I THINK SHE WAS A
FLIGHT ATTENDANT, COULD'VE BEEN
A PILOT.
SHE WORKS FOR SOUTHWEST.
>> Dana: SHE COULD HAVE BEEN A
PILOT.
>> Jesse: SHE HAD A UNIFORM
ON.
IT WAS HARD TO SEE.
AFTER SHE WAS MAD AT ME.
SAYING YOU TRASH SOUTHWEST.
I SAID THERE'S A LOT OF FIGHTS
THERE.
JUST DOING MY JOB AND THEN SHE
SAID JESSE, I'VE BEEN AT THIS
COMPANY FOR 22 YEARS AND THEY
ARE ABOUT TO FIRE ME BECAUSE I
HAVE THE ANTIBODIES BUT BECAUSE
OF MY RELIGIOUS REASONS, I DO
NOT WANT TO GET THE SHOT.
I'M ABOUT TO BE FIRED AFTER 23
YEARS.
SHE SAID A LOT OF THE OTHER
PEOPLE, THE OTHER PEOPLE AT THE
OTHER AIRLINES, THEY ARE GIVING
RELIGIOUS EXEMPTIONS.
AMERICAN AIRLINES, CHECK.
THEY WANT TO KEEP PEOPLE.
SOUTHWEST IS NOT DOING THAT.
THEY ARE BEING REAL TOUGH WITH
THAT AND SHE ACTUALLY PREDICTED
THAT THERE WAS GOING TO BE
ACTION TAKEN TO HAVE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS HAPPEN.
IN THE NEXT DAY, MONDAY, LOOK
WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Dana: IN AUGUST
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID THE SUPPLY
CHAIN CONCERNS REALLY TEMPORARY
AND THAT HIS EXPERTS HAD TOLD
HIM THAT THEY WOULD ALLEVIATE IT
IN THE ECONOMY WOULD IMPROVE.
WE ARE NOT SAYING THAT.
SHELVES ARE EMPTY.
NOW YOU HAVE AIRLINES SAYING THE
CASCADING EFFECT COULD BE THAT
THE ECONOMY DOES NOT IMPROVE.
>> WITHOUT QUESTION.
YOU SAW TODAY SOME OF THE
RETAILERS ARE CONTRACTING THEIR
OWN CARGO SHIP TO BRING IN
PRODUCTS TO MAKE SURE THERE ARE
PRODUCTS ON THE SHELVES FOR
THANKSGIVING AND CHRISTMAS.
THIS AIRLINE, THEY MISMANAGED
IT.
WHETHER IT'S A MANDATE OR NOT,
THEY SHOULD OF TOLD CONSUMERS ON
FLYERS THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
BE INCONVENIENCED.
THAT BEING SAID, IF I WERE A
PASSENGER ON SOUTHWEST AIRLINES
I WAS ON A PLANE WITH AN
UNVACCINATED PILOT WITH MY
UNVACCINATED 7-YEAR-OLD AND
6-YEAR-OLD, I WOULD WANT TO
KNOW.
I'M NOT SURE THEY ARE SHARING
IT.
I THINK THE AIRLINE IS PROBABLY
LOOKING AT THE LIABILITY AND
SAYING MAYBE IF WE DON'T HAVE
EVERYONE UNVACCINATED, WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE AN EVEN BIGGER SET
OF PROBLEMS.
AS I HAVE SHARED BEFORE, I
THOUGHT COLIN KAEPERNICK WAS
RIGHT FOR TEAMS TO BE ABLE TO
SAY YOU'VE GOT TO STAND WHEN THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM ISLAM.
THE PEOPLE DEFENDING THIS
FREEDOM PLATFORM, I APPLAUD YOU
BUT LET'S BE CONSISTENT.
THERE IS A CONSEQUENCE IF YOU
DON'T GET VACCINATED IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
THIS ISN'T THE GOVERNMENT
TELLING UNITED AIRLINES AND
SOUTHWEST, IT'S THAT AIRLINES
THINK WE WANT OUR PILOTS AND
THOSE WHO WORK FOR US
VACCINATED.
WE CAN DISAGREE.
EVERYONE HAS THE RIGHT TO
EXPRESS THEIR FREEDOM HOWEVER
THEY CHOOSE BUT THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES WHEN YOU DO YOUR
FREEDOM.
IF YOU WOULD'VE TOLD ME AT 2020
LAST YEAR, WE WERE IN A
PRESIDENTIAL RACE.
WE HAD OUR FIRST DEBATE.
BIDEN AND PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEN VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN.
IF YOU WOULD'VE TOLD ME A YEAR
LATER WE WOULD HAVE THREE
VACCINES AND THAT ONLY 60% OF
AMERICANS WILL BE FULLY
VACCINATED, LESS THAN 60%, I
WOULD'VE TAKEN A BET ON THE
OPPOSITE SIDE.
I WOULD'VE THOUGHT WE WOULD HAVE
THREE QUARTERS OF OUR NATION
VACCINATED.
THE FIRST THAT I CAME ON THE
SHOW, YOU ARE KIND TO HAVE ME
AND JESSE SAID CLEARLY IF
EVERYONE WHO IS VACCINATED
SOFTWARE MASKS, THAT'S WRONG.
I'M VACCINATED.
THE LIKELIHOOD OF ME GETTING
THIS VIRUS IS SO SMALL AND THE
LIKELIHOOD OF ME GETTING SICK IS
VERY SMALL.
INFANT.
INFINITESIMALLY SMALL.
THOSE NUMBERS STILL EXIST TODAY.
I HOPE PEOPLE GET VACCINATED AND
THOSE WHO CHOOSE NOT TO, THERE
WILL BE CONSEQUENCES.
OBVIOUSLY THE SOUTHWEST AIRLINE
PILOTS AND THE PERSONNEL THERE
ARE EXPERIENCING SOME OF THOSE
CONSEQUENCES.
>> Greg: I'M SORRY, YOU SAID
SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS AT THE
KERNEL OF THE PROBLEM.
THE QUESTION OF LIABILITY IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE RISK.
THE RISK IS SO SMALL.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
LIABILITY BUT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A PILOT THAT'S NOT GOING
TO HAVE ANY CONTACT WITH THE
6-YEAR-OLD OR THE 5-YEAR-OLD.
THE AIR CIRCULATION IN AN
AIRPLANE IS AMAZING.
>> I HEAR YOU BUT OF THE PILOT
IS COMMUNICATING AND HAS
INTERACTIONS WITH THE FLIGHT
CREW AND THE FLIGHT CREW IS
DELIVERING APPLE JUICE TO MY
6-YEAR-OLD OR 7-YEAR-OLD OR
GINGER ALE, THAT IS --
I'M NOT A DOCTOR.
I'M NOT A PROFESSIONAL.
ONE THING I DO KNOW, I DO NOT
WANT TO BE IN AN ENCLOSED
ENVIRONMENT WITH SOMEONE WHO'S
NOT VACCINATED.
>> DID YOU FLY BEFORE THE
VACCINE?
>> I DID NOT.
>> THE SPREAD OF COVID WAS NOT A
PROBLEM ON PLANES.
>> I DON'T WANT TO BE THE FIRST.
A LOT OF THIS IS THE FEAR OF THE
UNVACCINATED BY THE VACCINATED
AND THAT DEFIES THE LOGIC OF
GETTING VACCINATED IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
LET ME FINISH.
OKAY.
LAST YEAR WE ASKED AIRLINES,
EMPLOYEES TO GET BACK ON THE
JOB.
THE PILOTS AND FLIGHT ATTENDANTS
AND GATE AGENTS AND BAGGAGE
HANDLERS.
COME BACK TO WORK.
GET AMERICA BACK WELL BEFORE
THERE WAS A VACCINE.
THE SPREAD OF COVID ON
AIRPLANES, FULLY MASKED AND THEY
DO ENFORCE THOSE MASK MANDATES
ON AIRLINES AND THE AIRPORT.
THE VENTILATION SYSTEM ON THE
PLAINS.
TO ASK THESE INDIVIDUALS TO WORK
WHEN IT WAS CERTAINLY A LOT
RISKIER TO DO THAT LAST YEAR AND
THEN TO TELL THEM GET A VACCINE
OR YOU'RE FIRED, THAT'S
PROFOUNDLY UNFAIR.
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT.
DON'T YOU BELIEVE IN THE
SANCTITY OF THE UNION EMPLOYER
CONTRACT?
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
THE PILOTS ON FRIDAY AND THIS
LOOKS LIKE A --
25% OF FLIGHTS WERE CANCELED
YESTERDAY.
THERE'S A LAWSUIT FILED ON
FRIDAY BY THE PILOTS UNION.
THEY ARE CHALLENGING THE VACCINE
MANDATE IN COURTS BECAUSE THEY
SAY THAT IT VIOLATES THE RAILWAY
ACT.
I DIDN'T MEAN TO CUT YOU OFF.
>> BY NO MEANS.
>> Dagen: BEFORE WE GO, IF I
HAVE ONE -- HERE ONE MORE PEOPLE
SAY PACK YOUR PATIENTS IF
THEY'RE FLYING SOUTHWEST
AIRLINES, THEY SHOULD BE PELTED
BY STALE DOUGHNUTS.
>> Greg: THROW THEM OUT OF THE
EMERGENCY EXIT.
>> Dana: IF THEY TELL YOU IT'S
WEATHER-RELATED, THEN THEY DON'T
HAVE TO PAY FOR YOUR TIME.
THEY SAY IT'S NOT ABOUT THE
VACCINE.
>> Greg: DOES NOT WORK OUTSIDE
OF AIRLINES?
>> Dagen: IT'S A CREDITABILITY
-- CREDIBILITY PROBLEM.
>> THE COURTS WILL DECIDED.
>> Dana: THEY BETTER